ending the race grift that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
the man who was elected president of the
United States twice who graduated from
Harvard Law School
who owns close to 100 million dollars
worth of luxury homes in the most
exclusive enclaves of America
and who spends his Summers with
celebrities on Mega yachts in the
Mediterranean
that guy Barack Obama is now trying to
sell the notion that racism is the
Cornerstone of American Life
if
a Republican
who may even be sincere in saying I want
us all to live together doesn't have a
plan for how do we address
crippling generational poverty that is a
consequence of
hundreds of years of racism in the
society and we need to do something
about that there may come a time where
there's somebody
in the Republican party that is more
serious about actually addressing some
of the deep inequality that still exists
in our society
that tracks race and is a consequence of
our racial history
so by the way Tim Scott doesn't count it
is thinking but let me get this straight
this man was president for
eight years eight
eight so is America plagued by racism
when he won both elections handily
and if so
how could he have possibly won in such a
hostile environment
and if it was systemically racist when
he was president what work did he do in
his two terms to change that dynamic
is he actually trying to convince us
that the poverty and crime that has
gripped Urban America in places like New
York and Chicago Baltimore Philly that's
really the Vestige of the 19th century
slaveholders
now none of this racial talk none of it
is going to help black Americans
it will not create a single job
it won't change a single mind
but they're hoping it just might help
Democrats stay in power despite their
terrible record on the economy
now the truth is we populist
conservatives we have a set of policies
that work
that's why large numbers of Americans
from every demographic group blacks
included are leaving liberal enclaves
like San Francisco and Portland for
safer lower cost living sites
so the lies that Obama and the entire
Democrat Party continue to tell about
America are poison they're poisoned to
the body politic and all of us and it's
fraudulent just like the black lives
matter movement the movement they all
glommed on to after the death of George
Floyd
we have the the Brilliance of black
lives matter and that movement and what
it has done to force change it should be
celebrating black lives matter because
the continuity of evil in our country
has led us to this moment black lives
matter
period black lives matter should be very
much at the Forefront in every policy
that we ever do in this country
of course we know now that the entire
movement if that's what you really want
to call it was a scam
now we knew it at the time when we said
as much on the angle
but some Dopey Republicans who wanted to
be considered kind of cool and
respectable they threw in with their own
support
we need a voice Against Racism we need
many voices Against Racism and against
brutality we need to stand up and say
the black lives matter
The Mask outside always gives it away
probably you know has it on in his car
right now
how embarrassing ditto for all of the
mayors of America's failing cities of
course they're desperate to change the
subject from their disastrous records
the records that they tried to you know
hide and deflect from because they tried
to ride the BLM wave and they engaged in
pure political performance art
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah and no one riding the subways
now how powerful all of that was right
ignore the fact that our cities were
looted and trashed ignore the fact that
our schools were shuttered then as
protesters roam free
but as with everything the truth
eventually trickles out
soon after all those obsequious
corporate CEOs started filling blm's
coffers with millions and millions of
dollars in donations BLM reportedly
began to operate as a personal slush
fund not as a vehicle to help struggling
black Americans
and now it's bleeding millions in cash
despite by the way taking in a
staggering sum of 42 million dollars
after expenses in 2021. so where did all
that money go the auditor's review noted
that a sibling of the former executive
director owned a security company that
received more than 1.6 million dollars
in payments for something just labeled
Security Services
you know I say keep it in the family
just like the bidens keep it tight
now remember Patrice cullers right who
co-founded BLM she was nothing but
another ignorant anti-trumper
Trump not only needs to not be in office
in November but he should resign now um
we Trump needs to be out of office he is
not fit for office and so what we are
going to push for is a move to get Trump
out and another three million dollar
house
well of course she's the one who ended
up resigning she stepped down from BLM
leadership after questions were raised
about her lavish lifestyle and personal
real estate purchases
but it was obvious from day one that
this thing was run by self-absorbed
radical Marxist flim-flam artists who
hate all things traditional including
the nuclear family and the Catholic
Church
the top dog at blm's Calgary chapter in
Canada was arrested and charged with a
hate crime after blocking access to a
children's Catholic School
now do you notice how Obama Biden Harris
Mitt Romney they've all kind of silently
backed away
cat's got their tongue about the
grifters that propelled black lives
matter and same for the fact that their
beloved cities are collapsing under the
weight of the same Dynamics the misuse
of funds wasted money meaningless virtue
signaling and zero accountability
and it's finally catching up to him
brand new polling finds that support for
the BLM movement has tanked from 67
percent in 2020 to just 51 percent now
now the Democrats sell division they
sell racial hatred 24 7. because they
have a willing media that never calls
them out never ask the hard questions
never does a review of what was promised
in what was delivered
remember fact checks only go one way
so Republicans right now have a
tremendous opportunity here
so my question tonight on the angle is
are they going to take advantage of this
moment
or they're going to squander it as they
have so many times before
I'll say what I said on Election night
2020 when I was at the White House
take note of Florida and especially now
take note of South Florida where a
multi-ethnic multi-racial coalition is
delivering Real Results for all
Americans regardless of race and that's
the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else